you started though I didn't realize you
started doing voiceover which makes
sense now because I listen to your voice
without mellifluous oh I've got to get a
hell of a voice yeah yeah no I did I did
a lot of voices especially in my 20s and
it was ready time for an NCAA 20 cuz I'm
just trying to make my voice sound cool
okay alright I'm sorry to point it out
and make you embarrassed go ahead yeah
but that wou at that time in the
zeitgeist like the thing that that was
hip was to sound like you didn't care so
the all the voiceovers on TV commercials
what year we're talking about here this
was like too early 2000s like 2002 and
you'd see like a credit card commercial
and it was like hey man come get this
credit card because it'll make your life
easier you get some airline points but
we don't care we don't care if you get
it or not whatever that's terrible I
thought maybe reading that's for the
kind of stuff you were I was the
attitude it would be like want a coke
then go get one well there was this
weird sort of slacker aggro energy to
advertising a and that's what that's who
I was I was an aggro slacker would you
is there a company now that you see and
you say I Ed Helms would love to be the
voice for that company you know like so
this is this that's I love that question
yeah this is a strategic answer I will
answer with a company that I want three
things from okay and I would love to be
the voice of Tesla automobiles
although I've never seen a Tesla
commercial Tesla doesn't have
commercials they don't run commercial is
that I guess they just figure you know
what people that are gonna get a Tesla
are gonna get a Tesla ya don't need to
oh not just Tesla I want to be the voice
of like all the Elan musk stuff so I
want to be the voice of SpaceX I want a
rocket ship I want to be the first actor
and space yeah and I want it in my
driveway yeah
well this is your chance right now I
mean you have to say like with the cool
sleek lines would you do that or would
you act like you want a Tesla go get one
[ __ ] no I think a proton I don't
think it would work in today's today's
market I think today would be something
like Tesla it's cool if you get one
you're cool I think we're gonna start
you just on Hellmann's mayonnaise you
have to work your way Hellmann's
mayonnaise
I don't want three Hellmann's mayonnaise
good with hummons mayonnaise it's
fantastic true Hellmann's mayonnaise I'm
telling you I want it's really good Andy
have you ever had a bad sandwich with
Hellmann's mayonnaise I am NOT a
mayonnaise fan hey you know what shut up
this is a mayonnaise crowd I don't turn
hostile fetlocks I have convictions this
came in we're gonna see a pro mayonnaise
show States they may hear you pop off
about it I hope you get your Tesla gig I
really do thank you
you